hey guys and welcome to another chest
opening video today we are going to be
doing the muddy chest uh which are
opened by the muddy key obviously this
is a free-to-play chest that is located
in the Deep Wilderness in the lava maze
now um we went ahead and purchased
roughly 400 Keys uh and I know this is
going to be profitable to open but is it
going to be more of a is it actually
Worth to open these Keys uh kind of
depends on the price you get them for
and the technique in the way you go and
open them so hope you guys enjoy the
video and let's begin all right so you
can see here we have bought uh roughly
400 muddy Keys uh now these took quite a
while to buy so uh we did do a little
test run here just to see how long it
would take per run uh we have another
374 to claim and that will be good how
much we pay for these in total
925k um so what we're going to do is do
a test run here now um I've been kind of
trying to figure out the most efficient
way to do this and I believe um well
let's find the muddy Keys here first
clearly we're going to want a looting
bag so get that first a looting bag is
what we'll need most of all then I think
I'm going to try it first maybe
25 Keys cuz we're not going to be taking
everything uh for those who don't know
this is the contents of the muddy chest
and also worth noting is this is a free
to- playay item so you can open muddy
chest in free to play um it will always
give you this every time so one uncut
Ruby a mythal bar uh a mythal dagger
which will most likely drop then chovy
pizza two law runes two death runes 10
chaos runes and 50 coins uh this total
is up to about 6K or something and the
keys is only cost us well 2.2 uh so it's
a pretty good return now um since we'll
be dropping the daggers a bit of that
will be off it cuz the daggers are only
worth 80 coins or something that's not
worth it and uh and everything else is
pretty much stackable and we'll
try
20 H do
23 all cuz we have the Looting bag and
uh we'll also need a knife another item
that's going to be extremely useful is
the burning amulet it's a new amulet in
the game and it has a Teleport right to
the lava maze um so if you're not aware
it will teleport you
right here and which is a pretty close
way to get here and you have to run in
here and the U muddy chest is right here
it's a bit of a a far run but each key
is going to us about 3K and we're doing
23 keys so it'll be about well 66k
roughly uh per run and we're going to
see if we can do it in 5 minutes not
sure if we can or not but we'll give it
a try and uh yeah we got the knife
burning amulet and we'll need an amulet
of Glory which we have wearing right now
and that is to teleport back to
Edgeville and I think that's all we need
all right let's give it a shot all right
so we're just put ready to go so what
we're going to be doing is is
teleporting Into the Wilderness with the
burning amulet that is going to pop us
out right um here uh which is pretty
close right the entrance to the maze
we're going to run through the maze open
up the muddy chest toss all the items in
the Looting bag Barn the mythal dagger
and then we're going to run out so let's
go ahead and do a run for you guys uh so
we're going to go to rub and then the
lava maze the third option yes I want to
teleport to level 41
Wilderness so we're not going to drink
our stamina potion right away uh because
we want that for our run out so first of
all you have to run a little bit north
in sl's web
here and from here we're going to go a
little bit north it's really easy maaz
to get through guys that's not that
challenging uh from here we're going to
go through the middle
path and once you get to the end uh
we're going to go through the most
eastern path and there's just one more
we to cut through it's a really short
Maze and unfortunately we don't actually
have the shortcut available which is 82
agility that being said I don't really
think it would actually save a lot of
time actually probably wouldn't save
much time at all honestly may even take
longer once we're on the Eastern path
cut this web
here and we're going to run into the
maze now uh one thing worth noting is
there are lesser demons which will
attack you and can kind of [__] you up
if you are lower level and everything
else will attack you as well um but but
you can kind of get them stuck on the
chest which is pretty easy to do and
definitely worth it so once we're in
here the money chest is just over here
and also a steel plate body which is
cool mainly this one over here will
harass you uh so let's go ahead and see
if he starts attacking me otherwise just
going to start using keys on the chest
just click use and what I do is use them
all on the keys all the keys on the
chest sorry and uh we'll let all the
items on the ground for now first we're
just going to lure this guy over here a
little bit and then run back so we can
open up the chest and he should get
stuck perfect so now what we're going to
do is just use all the keys on the chest
I know the items are dropping on the
ground but it'll just kind of be easier
to deal with them once they're just all
in the open like that and that should be
the last item or last key Ed there we go
so now we have all the items in the
ground we'll use the myth bars on the
Looting bag and put all of them in there
and now we're going to pick up the
stackables and unfortunately we're going
have to pick up all these daggers CU
they're kind of in the way but we'll
just go drop them on to the side because
we don't want them and so come drop them
over here with the new shift drop
feature this is not too bad at
all and then go pick up the rest of the
stack now we're going to maybe refine
how much uh Keys We takes I'm not really
sure if this is going to work out
properly or not and now on to the Ruby
is good and the an pizzas and then
deposit those in our looting bag as
well so I think we might have a few too
many
possibly and we have 18 pizzas left to
pick up and we're going to leave how
many behind at looks like nine so
possibly we may want to even reduce the
amount of keys we take by one more even
I'll pick up one more pizza and that's
pretty much all we can scr together
loing bag is full correct yes all right
well next time we'll bring maybe only 16
keys and all we're going to do is run
out of here and teleport out all right
so I ran back here and did another run
and it looks like uh 16 is pretty much
the perfect amount you're left with one
extra inventory slot which is fine but
but as you can see everything has been
used we have all our stackables and uh
all the enchy pizzas and if we look at
our looting bag it is full of the mythal
bars and the uncut rubies now this run
usually takes about 5 minutes so 5
minutes for 16 Keys it's going to take a
while guys so we're going to go ahead
grind out the rest of these keys and
we'll come back when we are done all
right so that is our last inventory of
keys and uh this probably took about 2
hours in total to do all 400 Keys
roughly and uh my original question was
is it worth it to open muddy keys I knew
that it would be profitable I mean the
items in them are worth more and you get
them every time so there was no question
about that but more if it's actually
worth it to open the keys and I would
actually say yes it is um mainly because
we're going to get close to 1 mil in
profit maybe even more and only took us
2 hours that's five or 600k an hour uh
with little requirements you none
actually all you need is a burning am
amulet a looting bag and an amulet of
glory and the keys all can be bought on
a level three if you wanted and also
this can be modified to a free-to-play
world not as good money per hour but
still doable so yeah I would say it's
worth doing uh if you get some keys uh
buy them off the grand exchange just put
an offer in eventually they'll come up
with a few and uh can be decent money so
we'll go ahead go back to the Grand
exchange and see how much everything
will sell for all right we are back at
the Grand exchange and we have about 20K
coins 8 104 law runes 804 death runes 4K
chaos runes 400 uncut rubies only 370
anov pizzas because we [__] that up a
little bit and same thing with the
mythal bars just in the beginning we
didn't know how many we needed and we
ended up dropping some stuff on the
ground so let's go ahead and price check
it so of course 20K is worth 20K law
runes are about 160k um chaos runes in
uncut rubies we're up to about 1.5 mil
and CH pizz is 1.9 mil and everything in
is 2.2 mil closer to 2.3 and keep in
mind we bought these for about 950k so
that is a 1.2 or 1.3 mil profit uh which
is really good considering it only took
us about two hours to do uh which I'm
pretty happy with and like I said you
could modify this to be free to play if
you wanted money per hour wouldn't be as
good so we're going to insta sell all
the items here and we'll see how much
money we are left with and that's it
guys we have sold everything so let's
collect and see how much cash we end up
with looks like about 2.2 mil so we lost
about 50 or 60k insta selling it but
that's not a big deal so I think uh
buying money keys and opening them is
definitely worth it if you have the
patience to a buy all the keys and open
them up I think it's easy money and
definitely worth it so hope you guys
enjoyed the video and I'll see you guys
in the next one
[Music]